fun science fun science fun science is a
science of fun yeah today I'd like to
tell you some cool things about light ah
now as I'm sure you're aware the speed
of light is 299,792,458 meters per
second which is pretty bloomin fast to
give you an idea as to how fast that
actually is it would take a beam of
light 1.25 five seconds to travel from
the earth to the moon the speed of sound
is only 340 meters per second which is
still pretty fast even though thanks to
science humans have managed to go faster
than that but if you want to go faster
than light then sorry you can't it's not
possible it's theoretically possible
that we could one day travel very very
nearly almost as fast as light but to go
faster than that's no sorry now before I
can tell you about all of the really
cool stuff that comes with light in the
speed of light I have to tell you about
this other thing called the Doppler
effect which is still really interesting
so you know don't leave just yet the
Doppler effect is the change that you
notice in the frequency of a wave when
the source of that wave is moving
relative to you for example imagine that
you're sitting by a canal enjoying the
lovely British weather when suddenly I
appear next to you screaming like a
lunatic from your perspective it's just
really really weird
however if theoretically I wasn't
standing next to you but was running
past you at 80 miles an hour still
screaming just as I was before as I
approach you the pitch of my screen
would be higher
and then as I pass and run away from you
the pitch of my scream would drop even
though from my perspective I'm screaming
at exactly the same pitch as I was when
I was standing still
the reason this shift in pitch happens
is because when I'm sitting still and
screaming ah the sound waves are
emitting from my mouth uniformly but
when I start moving the sound waves in
front of me gets squished up and the
sound waves behind me get stretched out
and it's this change in the frequency
that causes the change in pitch as I
pass and that is what the Doppler effect
is the reason the Doppler effect is
important is because it doesn't just
apply to sound but it also applies to
light but you didn't see that one coming
kiss it's not a video about light or
anything like that is it oh so just as
when something is moving and emitting
sound you can hear a difference in the
pitch of that sound when something is
moving and emitting or reflecting light
you can see a difference in the color of
that light for example imagine that
we're in exactly the same running canal
situation as before it's at this time
I'm not screaming like a lunatic and
instead of running at 80 miles an hour
I'm running very very merely almost the
speed of light
what would you say well you probably
wouldn't see anything at all because as
you'll remember the speed of light is
very very very fast and I'd be gone
before you even knew I was there but
let's pretend that you had a magic
iPhone app that would let you take
pictures of me traveling very nearly at
the speed of light what would you see
well when I'm ready towards you the
light in front of me gets squished and
the frequency of that light gets shifted
to the blue end of the visible light
spectrum and so I appear blue and then
as you see me running away from you the
same thing happens in Reverse the light
behind me get stretched out shifts to
the red end of the spectrum and then I
appear to be slightly red now this
change in the frequency of light is
something that happens all the time in
fact it's happening right now as I move
forwards and backwards from you but the
change is so negligible that you can't
notice it unless something is traveling
at very very nearly the speed of light
but easily the coolest thing that
happens when you travel at very very
nearly almost the speed of light is that
when you do time slows down o'clock's
whether man-made or biological like me
tick slower when you're traveling that
fast so back to our thought experiment
where I have the ability to run
very nearly at the speed of light
imagine that I decided to take a couple
of minute to around London traveling
that fast well it might have only seemed
like a couple of minutes to me but to
you traveling at normal human speed it
would have been many many years and so
by the time I returned from my very
short run you would have died of old age
and that ladies and gentlemen is light
this is the end bye you've just had the
almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool
you